ex alumna de saint expo paris esta mujer
a la que llamaremos sara fue agredida
durante un evento escolar que reunía a
escuelas de distintas ciudades francesas
decidió darnos su testimonio de forma
anónima
al principio es una competición
deportiva pero también hay novatadas una
gran fiesta en la que todos se mezclan
guaje
y de hecho apenas llegué a la fiesta un
chico me agarró por el cuello y me besó
a la fuerza
y de hecho metió las manos debajo de mi
falda y me metió un dedo y en realidad
en ese momento yo estaba un poco
borracha y no era realmente consciente
de lo que estaba pasando
y fue cuando volví al hotel por la noche
que se lo conté una amiga hay un hueco
en mis medias me agredieron
pero creo que en ese momento no me
atrevía a quejarme o hablar de ello
porque pensé que dañaría el ambiente si
hubiera estado con el ánimo en el que me
encuentro hoy no habría dudado en
denunciarlo
además es alfred desde el fenómeno michu
hay más libertad para hablar en las
redes sociales hay muchas alumnas de las
escuelas de la red science po salen del
silencio para dar testimonio de la
violencia que han sufrido sus hashtag
ciencias cerdos sentimientos de
impunidad
ambiente sexista pasividad por parte de
la administración puntos comunes entre
todos los testimonios recogidos por
fanny magris de su investigación
publicada en el diario liberation
se beneficia de esta imagen de crear las
élites políticas y económicas y de un
sistema corporativista y elitista
bastante fuerte dos sistemas en cheste
pediremos contribuye un poco a perpetuar
cierto silencio
si nos denuncia un sistema de
silenciamiento de las víctimas cómo
podemos ayudar a las víctimas qué se
puede hacer qué puede hacer la escuela
de que es responsable la administración
y qué herramientas tiene realmente los
estudiantes a su disposición de
cuestiones que van mucho más allá del
ámbito de science por la violencia de
género y sexual afecta a toda la esfera
estudiantil en francia en 2019 una de
cada diez estudiantes fue agredida
sexualmente y una de cada 20 fue violada
ante ese fenómeno el ministerio de
educación superior ha lanzado una
campaña de sensibilización y de
formación del personal universitario
y desde 2018 las instituciones están
obligadas a crear una unidad de atención
especializada para que las víctimas
puedan ser realmente escuchadas del
externa gris de paz se optó por
exteriorizar no porque uno de los
problemas más fuertes en los aspectos de
la violencia de género es la dificultad
de hablar porque es más fácil hablar con
un interlocutor neutral
y también porque el apoyo es
multidisciplinar es decir psicológico
jurídico médico y social fuera compañero
de prueba en disciplina efe esto no
impide por supuesto que asumamos
nuestras responsabilidades sobre todo en
materia disciplinaria con todo
responsabilidad notamos jong hee kim e
iniciativas bienvenidas pero desiguales
entre las instituciones y a menudo muy
poco conocidas todas nosotras es un
movimiento nacional contra la violencia
sexual y de género en la universidad de
parís 1 la sección local de todas
nosotras se ha propuesto informar a las
víctimas sobre los recursos de que
disponen pero según ellos lo primero que
hay que hacer es cambiar de mentalidad
estas asociaciones antes de organizar
grandes fiestas y grandes fines de
semana de integración tienen que conocer
todos los límites que hay que poner y
creo que también se trata de educar al
personal de estas asociaciones para que
puedan detectar y prevenir toda esta
violencia y para asegurarse o eso espero
al menos de que ocurra cada vez menos o
incluso de que no ocurra siendo
optimista un mensaje que la asociación
también está difundiendo en las redes
sociales donde a veces es más fácil que
las víctimas se expresen las redes
permiten compartir de forma sencilla y
concienciar al máximo es cierto que es
nuestra principal herramienta de
sensibilización y comunicación este
espacio mediático arroja luces sobre los
casos de violencia sexual pero no
sustituye un sistema de justicia que
sigue siendo demasiado titubeante soy
una ex estudiante de la escuela de altos
estudios comerciales de parís terminé el
año pasado víctima de un intento de
violación durante un fin de semana de
integración mari conocía a su agresor
de hecho era uno de los miembros
supervisores un estudiante que debía
controlar la salida y si tuve que volver
a cruzarme con él porque la escuela no
tomó ninguna medida aparte de decirme
aléjate mucho no hables mucho con ellos
creo que lo que faltaba era la ayuda del
gobierno para hacer algo fuera de un
procedimiento externo fue ya lo hiciste
presentaste una denuncia y ahora estamos
esperando y mientras tanto no podemos
hacer nada eso es todo
la denuncia fue desestimada por falta de
pruebas
como después
en francia se estima que alrededor del
10% de las víctimas de violación
presentan una denuncia
sólo el 7 por ciento se van a una
condena